man we are cruising tonight we're gonna
get home early enough to watch Desperate
Housewives oh this is a ladies and
gentlemen please welcome two-time
Academy Award winner Dustin Hoffman
good evening so the saying goes if it
ain't broke don't fix it
well when you adapt material from a
novel or a short story or some other
source you have to take something that
works and then you have to break it and
then you have to fix it and then you
have to turn it into a film that works
and that ain't easy the nominees for
Best Screenplay almost opened it it's so
much easier to act and do the stuff
great work I'm looking at everybody who
didn't win great work you people great
work
sorry excuse me I'll never get invited
again the nominees for Best Screenplay
based on material previously produced or
published are Larry McMurtry and Diana
asana for growth back Mountain based on
the short story by any fool
dan Futterman for Capote based on the
books by Gerald Clark Jeffrey King but
the constant gardener based on the novel
by John McCrae
Josh Olsen for a history of violence
based on a graphic novel by John Wagner
and Vince Locke Tony Kushner and Eric
Roth from Munich
based on the book vengeance the true
story of an Israeli counter-terrorist
team by George Jonas
and the Oscar goes to Larry McMurtry
Dianne reshawna for Brokeback Mountain
this is the first Academy Award and
second nomination for Larry McMurtry he
was previously nominated for the last
picture show this is the first Academy
awarded second nomination tonight for
Diana son
she's also nominated in the Best Picture
category
thank you to the Academy the duty of art
is to send light into the darkness of
men's hearts thank you any Prue she's
right over there for trusting us with
your brilliant short story
thank you to Anglian our brilliant cast
for breathing life into our words thank
you to the universal Focus Features bill
pohlad Michael Costigan my dear friend
my good friend Mark Poirier for giving
me the New Yorker that had that short
story in it and thank you to my writing
partner Larry thank you for giving him
the sword as well since somehow I
unaccountably failed to thank my
brilliant partner Diana at the Golden
Globes I'm going to rattle off all the
attributes I was going to thank her for
at the Golden Globes smarts guts drive
good judgment tenacity loyalty and
generosity that's the kind of virtues
you need in the rough strife of
moviemaking like to thank also James and
Curtis my son and grandson with love and
pride thank our loyal lawyers Robert
thorn and Greg Rutledge and finally I'm
going to thank all the booksellers of
the world
remember the Brokeback Mountain was a
book before it was a movie from the
humblest paperback exchange to the
Masters of the great book shops of the
world all our contributors to the
survival of the culture of the book a
wonderful culture which we mustn't lose
thank you